foreign
[Music]
we came to Rome to shoot a chasing
something with a lot more ambition and
unpredictability that we haven't had in
previous chases
we'll be screaming through the streets
of Rome Motorcycles
Cars everything that we shot is
completely practical
we're doing it right
it all comes down to one thing how do we
involve the audience I just want to give
them that thrill
[Music]
[Applause]
we let the city tell us the kind of
Chase it was going to be traffic in the
city is notorious and the cobblestone
streets may fall to the driving
unpredictable
best part is Tom and Haley
they're handcuffed together people are
chasing us yes they are you're driving
let's drive one handicapped for real no
cheating it the key is don't crash
thank you
he's that person I have no idea
Thomas driving and drifting one-handed
through the streets of Rome that was a
day I will never forget trying to do
drifts every time you think you're going
in One Direction it's the cobblestones
on the street saying no you're not
you're going this way
you gotta get rid of this car
[Applause]
tell me how to ditch the car for one of
their IMF there because
suddenly this tiny little Fiat 500 comes
out of nowhere we built this Fiat 500
so that it would be faster
you could barely control the car it was
Treacher
Fiat that was wild some would even say
the car is possessed
I don't think we could have made a
sequence that was more difficult to
shoot if I had gone out of my way to do
it it has really amazing results
would be impossible without this crew of
an actor like Tom
right we lost them
Our Lives
are the sum of our choices
[Music]
it cannot escape the past
the mission of yours
is gonna cost you dearly
the world is changing
truth is Vanishing war is coming
it's been a long time
you've no idea the power I represents
ignores your story and How It Ends
listen to me the world's coming after
you
his fate is written shall we write yours
too if anything happens to them there's
no place that at all go to kill you that
is written
foreign
what's your objective
what's your ultimate objective
your life will always matter more to me
than my own
none of our Lives can matter More Than
This Mission I don't accept that
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]